welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is the breakdown of the
falcon the winner soldier episode 3
power broker where the real power
belongs to zemo and sharon carter i'm
gonna break down and translate all the
hidden details
and evidence of a massive remove subplot
in the series that was kind of easy to
overlook okay we open with a promo video
from the global repatriation council
this is the agency in charge of
resources and resettlement for blip
refugees
helping you navigate changes to society
laws and borders
borders huh well rhodey did talk about
how international alliances had shifted
during the blip and now it is hinted
here that maps have been redrawn
as zemo later confirms with sokovia the
grc logo is this globe with small dots
growing larger and joining together
reflecting a person re-materializing
from dust as we saw with monica rambo
and wandavision and from this peaceful
message we smash cut the grc logo on a
police swat van
yeah uncovering itself to the shield
and john walker not at all helping
helpless don't give him a second
delete shred or breathe yikes
this guy just told police officers
don't give him a second to breathe this
week
of all weeks john walker you gotta say
something like that they bust the german
who sheltered the flag smashers
lamar new translator walker can't
communicate
basic german let alone question this guy
respectfully enough to get him to speak
in english which he totally can
do you know who i am
yes i do and i don't care meanwhile both
sam
and bucky are multilingual sam speaks
arabic bucky understands japanese on top
of the romanian he spoke in civil war
these two are heroes without borders
whereas walker fights for one country
and hoskins tells him
she's giving displaced people shelter
and medicine that kind of thing creates
loyalty man i know you want this but
we've literally tried everything we can
here
so someone's langley setting up a future
split between these two
now that walker seems to be spiraling
deeper into rage now they also mentioned
langley here and the cia does come up
later as a previous employer to dr
nagel so langley might have actually
been leaving walker in the
dark to keep secret their involvement in
this super soldier serum development and
then bucky needs zemo now last week the
video feed labeled his cell as 2187
a reference to princess leia's cell in
star wars but for whatever reason now
it's 61.72 which maybe you can see as a
reference to a dark avengers dark rain
comic but really folks
any string of numbers can be a reference
to some comic issue or publication date
unless the comic issue is super specific
to the scenario the characters are in
it's probably not an easter egg but
notice the music when bucky walks in
yeah composer henry jackman brings back
zemo's melody from civil war
and if you continue to listen as zemo
repeats the winter soldier activation
code words
[Music]
those days are over jackman's winter
soldiers scream
creeps back in but that echo goes silent
as bucky shoes him away with his line
saying those days are over he is
currently in control of this now all
this plays out concurrently with
buckingham's later meeting which is kind
of a screenwriting tool
of heist in progress where characters
will explain a
seemingly hypothetical future plan while
we intercut with that plan
actually already in progress it kind of
saves time it helps with the pace scene
but
in this case with zemo i will say it did
make his escape feel a bit
easy but i am interested in how bucky
asks zemo
what's the book you're reading
machiavelli
nicolo machiavelli was a political
theorist known for the concept of civic
for two
wherein the most virtuous and just
leader acts not according to any
stubborn ideology that he holds but
maneuvers as necessary keeping people
guessing machiavelli popularized the
idea of the ends justify the means which
zemo actually echoes in his words to
bucky
it was never personal you were simply a
means
to a necessary end zemo is certainly a
machiavellian figure in the way that he
now puts his old avengers hatred behind
him to use falcon and bucky towards some
new
end goal but what is that goal exactly
well look closely at his book
this is actually a german version of
roger d master's
fortune is a raging river how leonardo
da vinci and nicolo machiavelli wanted
to change history so this book isn't
just about machiavelli
but machiavelli's friendship with
contemporary italian renaissance figure
and fellow florence resident
leonardo da vinci and how their
complimentary world views shaped the new
age of civilization
so if zemo sees himself as machiavelli
who is his silent partner his da vinci
that he's not telling bucky about
who's his enlightened inventor his
seeker of the vitruvian man
well we might get a clue in the next
scene these are mine
collected by family over the generations
so uh zemo's rich in fact you almost
expect to see
among this collection of the hottest
wheels in the mcu
the v16 roadster which is driven by red
skull
in the first cap film which red skull
handed off to
whom not a scratch doctor not a scratch
yes arnhem zola red skull's right-hand
man who reappeared in winter soldier as
an ai algorithm revealing through the
lines of computer code he corrupted
shield
into hydra since the 70s marvel studios
loves this guy so much he even
reappeared in avengers end game with
howard and tony talking about him and a
little visual cameo in the background
and the in-game screenwriters have said
they want to see him come back in a
future marvel title with his robotic
android body from the comics now
mt and i have been on this zola train
since before this season even began we
could actually get
a zola cameo i was about to say the same
thing
i think we're on the solar train
and back in that first cat film zola
joined red skull in his davincian
obsession with the perfect human form an
obsession that led to zola's design
of his android body for himself which
was a little visual easter egg in that
movie
so if zemo does have a silent partner
his family's fortune
could be rooted in a link to the
fortunes of johann schmidt
and his partner zola now in one of these
cars is zemo's iconic purple mask from
the comics where
he was the son of baron heinrich zemo a
nazi scientist his son helmut zemo
adopts his father's white supremacist
views well really his zemo supremacist
views and leads villain groups like the
masters of evil and later the
thunderbolts and now zemo dons this coat
with a fur collar evoking that look from
the comics
so all this time you've been rich i'm a
baron sin
my family was royalty until your friends
destroyed my country
hmm your friends destroyed my country
i mean i know he's talking about the
avengers wrecking sokovia but you know
just paired with that butler's cringe at
sam
in particular and then how they laughed
up serving them rotten food
and then zemo's kind of virtue signaling
about marvin gaye
there's just a lot of red hat red flags
there and then add that to the jab about
sam's incarceration
you don't know what it's like to be
locked in a cell
oh that's right you do but yes referring
to sam's time locked up in the raft in
civil war
and then zema finds bucky's list with
more names visible than when we last saw
it like jay weaver could be for john
weaver a digital asset coordinator for
the show l hudson is a pa on the show
then l atwood of course for senator
atwood from episode one and we learned
that this is actually the same exact
notebook that steve rogers wrote his
list in and captain america the winner
soldier
so he must have given it to bucky as a
way to help bucky acquaint himself in
modern life but instead bucky has to use
it to list
past wrongs he must write like he can't
move on to new things until he clears
those demons
and then sam reminds us how he actually
told steve to write down troubleman
and they debate about marvin gaye and
this episode actually came out on marvin
gaye's birthday but look at the book
that zemo has behind it peter shell and
bombs
darn nine in deliberate translating to
the no in love
deep limitation and devotion in the
erotic relationship it's a relationship
psychology book from 1986 that instead
of using
psychology terms it used a lot of
allusions to greek mythology to try to
explain it you know who else was
obsessed with mythology
red skull whom zemo brings up here as a
young soldier sent to germany to stop a
mad icon do we want to live in a world
full of people like the red skull
now moving on there is this really weird
moment in the scene with carly and mama
donya
carly you gotta come upstairs
there's not much time you should be with
her now
yeah i notice that we never see who is
talking to carly here
also we hardly meet mamadonia despite
them casting veronica falcone
a talented actress with a large body of
work so what's going on here well
this was likely condensed during
reshoots this was
new dialogue dubbed over it and then it
was all re-edited after rumors last year
that a subplot in this series had to be
altered due to similarities with the
covet 19 pandemic remember in episode 2
there were mentions of vaccines
that they never really followed up on
and then notice later in this episode
when dr nagle talks about
donya again the camera cuts away his
audio quality shifts a little bit when
he says which disease she was suffering
from
but a couple of days ago she called and
asked if i could help someone
named donya madani poor woman has
tuberculosis
typical of overpopulation and
displacement camps like that
so it's looking very likely that there
was some disease outbreak subplot in the
falcon of the winter soldier which
explains why the flag smashers stole
vaccines in particular why donya died
and why this new scene later with dovich
puts a hood over aaron keleman's head
because her hair might have been
different during these reshoots
so look folks if you find any editing
confusing in the series it might just be
because they constructed an entirely new
storyline to which i say
you know you could have just left
whatever it was the more relevant with
what we're going through the better
probably but whatever i don't know what
it was
still we do get this detail of donya
carrying a hamsa pendant this has
spiritual significance to many religions
it's kind of used to ward off the evil
eye
here the eye has been replaced with a
globe explaining the origin of the flag
smasher symbol and that dania may have
been kind of a matriarch to this
organization look these characters out
of their comfort zones because sure
let's be honest they're trying to wear
suits that don't fit them right wearing
someone else's clothes just feels wrong
kind of like sleeping a mattress made
for someone else quit sleeping on the
wrong kind of mattress and give yourself
a personalized helix mattress
love that segway i love that segway
helix mattresses are made in america and
shipped to your door with free delivery
free returns and a 100 night sleep trial
to choose a mattress helix made a quiz
that takes just two minutes and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or really firm or if you sleep on
your side or on your stomach or if you
sleep really hot with helix there's a
specific mattress for your unique taste
i took the quiz and got matched with the
dusk looks helix mattress because i
wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support
sleeps cool i sleep great on this helix
mattress helix was awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick
of 2020 by gq wired magazine and
apartment therapy
so go to helixsleep.com rockstars take
their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress for the best sleep of your life
they even have a 10-year warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it felix is
offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
rockstars felixsleep.com rockstars for
up to 200
off and two free pillows and then
magipore a criminal haven located near
singapore divided into high town and
lowtown we actually saw this teased on a
postcard in the end credits with
filipino tagalog
translating to one world one people and
the music that actually plays during
their entrance
is filipino raptrack amats by shanti
dope sam has to disguise himself as
conrad mack the smiling tiger an actual
character in the comics he's a villain
who later became part of the
thunderbolts during the civil war event
and among all these signs in low town is
the princess bar
a dive visited by wolverine in the
comics when he goes under his patch
logan alias and then wall art warning
power broker is watching very big
brother is watching
and then the monkey face of the logo of
the brass monkey saloon which is another
magical location from the comics we've
also seen this facing the end credits
with chinese characters over it
translating to gold corruption
and accomplice inside sharon carter sees
them and then she sneaks off and then
moments later
got word from on high you ain't
welcoming
i have no business with a power broker
but if he insists he can either come and
talk to me
hmm sharon carter could be working for
this power broker
but she probably isn't the power broker
herself she just seems like a mobile
operative she's on the street she's
killing people she's
getting out there she doesn't seem like
someone sitting on a throne as zemo
describes the power broker
by the way using the pronoun he every
kingdom needs its king
let's just pray we stay on his radar in
madrid he's judge jewelry and
executioner
so the power broker is likely some
marvel crime lord
we have yet to meet and my money is on
the mandarin
the true mandarin not trevor's lottery
the one going to be played by tony liang
in chiang chi
the leader of the ten rings crime
organization someone who cares a lot
about his reputation and with a vast
network of spies whom we've seen
throughout the mcu
zemo has some bad blood with them which
might have come from the deleted scene
in captain america civil war in which
zemo gasses a bunch of other
international arms dealers which could
have included some of the power brokers
men
zemo forces bucky back into his winter
soldier role and notice how the winter
soldier scream returns but it doesn't
subside this time it intensifies
and zemo feeds this berserker violence
by throwing a dude at bucky this all
happens while patrons record it on their
phones meaning the terms of bucky's
pardon
specifically dr raynor's whole second
rule about not hurting anyone
are being totally violated here it's
probably going to justify any
lethal force walker wants to use to
catch bucky and bring him down
and they meet selby played by imelda
corcoran who played dr goodman and
agents of shield there are actually a
few celebs in marvel comics like selby
the mutant
suzanne selby from roxon either way she
gets killed by sharon's sniper bullet
alerting every nearby assassin
if this feels like something from the
john wick films maybe because this
episode was written by derek colstad
creator of that franchise
sharon sells famous artwork including
vincent van gogh self-portrait and
claude monet's woman with a parasol
which is supposed to hang in the
national gallery of art in washington dc
which is right across the national mall
from the museum where cap's exhibit is
so the same way that sam was shocked to
see his valuable that belonged in a
museum get taken out and exploited
so too is he here learning that nothing
is sacred so sylvia told him about dr
wilfred
nagel who gets its name from the
scientist in the comics who was part of
project rebirth
which enhanced isaiah bradley both he
and dr erskine have used the alias of dr
reinstein in the comics and notice this
line from sharon though we got a name
wilfred nagel
nagel works for the power broker we need
your help sharon
another sneaky audio dub there sharon's
line was totally off screen with these
awkward edits so we don't see her face
i suppose they needed a direct link
between nagel and the power broker to
set up how
sharon would know how to get this info
from these architraders or maybe some
other re-edited coveted subplot residue
then at the party zemo breaks the
internet
[Music]
then on to the match reports shipyard
where there are a bunch of flags these
are for the nation of magipore
one of these also appeared on sharon's
plate earlier and you'll notice sharon
is using the 2013 era phone the same
kind that nick fury uses in winter
soldier
suggesting that she might still be using
the same encrypted tech when she's going
off grid that she was using back in
those days so when dr nagel first sees
zemo notice they exchange this
look it seems like nagel might have
known he was on zemo's list of past
hydra serum scientists that zemo said he
was hunting down and that nagel in this
moment knows that he might be done so so
nagel explains that he started with
hydra to recreate the serum but then he
worked for the cia who had the blood of
an american test subject definitely
referring to isaiah bradley and that
with that he was able to crack the code
i did what no other scientist since
erskine
was able to do but mine was going to be
different
mine was going to be subtle optimized
perfect meanwhile outside sharon goes
ape [ __ ] on these bounty hunters there's
some great john wick style stunts here
especially with the knife work likely
done with the cgi blade which you can
spot in a few places like when the dude
takes it out of his arm but then
later it's not in his hand anymore and
there's really no sound effect of it
dropping despite there being tons of
other knife sound effects
because when he pulled it out of his arm
there was just nothing in his hand they
cgi that in and then similarly later
when sharon maneuvers the knife for a
brief second
it kind of drops a frame and it jumps
from one angle to another within a
single frame i'm not pointing this out
to criticize i love seeing this because
it's a reminder that hey this stun team
was being safe and kids you should not
play around with knives at home
and then as she wrestles this one dude
there's a tattoo on his arm this is
french translating to
we have only scratched the surface a
little so this all ends with zemo
shooting nagel and the lab explodes
scattering nagel's vials
now he had claimed there wasn't any
serum in the lab but the close-ups frame
the vials and the flasks it kind of
makes it seem like zemo or one of the
others could have grabbed one of these
whether or not this serum was complete
effective serum so maybe zemo could end
up offering this as a trick to john
walker which could lead to dangerous
side effects and bring him down from the
inside i mean hey sam and bucky got to
get that shield somehow i love how
director kari skogland frames zemo's
mask similar to the way christopher
nolan framed his opening shot of the
joker in the dark knight
a sinister pose framing the mask in the
gunslinger position
right before the black cat draws it like
a weapon by putting it on his face
and then bucky ruins this person's day
and then zemo rolls up in another sweet
ride you're not gonna move your seat up
are you
no uh of course i call back to winter
soldier can you move your ceiling
no and then sharon shadily tells her
driver got a big problem
actually a couple of them i'll tell you
in the car let's go yeah i do think she
is working for the power broker and her
couple problems are that nagel is dead
and that some of his vials may have been
taken like maybe in her mind she led
these guys here so that they could use
nagel to find the flag smashers and put
them down
not kill nagel and destroy all their
product then in latvia zemo says
i heard what became of sokovia
cannibalized by its neighbors
erased from the map so sokovia is
located in eastern europe and maybe part
of its redrawn map could include the
nation of latvia also in eastern europe
home to victor von doom kevin feige
confirmed that we have a fantastic four
movie in the works sometime in the next
few years
zemo also mentions the sokovia memorial
which trailer footage shows him visiting
at some point in the series and then
bucky follows a trail of comoyo beads
the vibranium tech used by the people of
wakanda leading bucky2ao
so ayo is the second in command of the
dora milage right under okoye she was
actually the first store milaje that we
met back in civil war and she returned
in black panther and an infinity war she
was last seen fighting corvus glaive
protecting shuri in vision and i love
how her cameo comes in with this music
of the wakandan drums and the african
female singing group
chanting that ryan coogler and ludwig
joranson uses the dormilage a warrior
theme
[Music]
now as sam warned earlier this episode
wakanda is not gonna let it go that zemo
killed king t'chaka and are probably not
too happy about his release i also
speculated inside marvel that this whole
black panther crossover could shed light
on the long time mystery ingredient to
erskin's serum formula an ingredient
that i think could have been derived
from the wakandan heart-shaped herb
now i do assume it's a bit too early to
learn what marvel's plans are for black
panther 2 after chadwick boseman's
passing so i don't think we're going to
hear any references to t'challa in the
show but at the very least
bucky's role as the white wolf of
wakanda could still be key
to his future oh by the way this is our
anarchy assembled shirt available at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow me rockstars and subscribe
to new rockstars here on youtube for
breakdowns of everything marvel thanks
for watching
[Music]
you